so fans here are amazing and the fans of
your show are amazing
the story's weights getting cancelled
fans bring you guys back how does that
feel it felt really really great because
sometimes I think we make these shows
and you're not even sure if people watch
them or if they love them and even with
all the social media sometimes it can
feel like it's a little bit of a vacuum
or a bubble but this was undeniable the
fans brought back our show we were
canceled on a Wednesday and resurrected
by a Saturday we had a true on
television resurrection story which I've
never even heard of before so I thought
television resurrection story yeah yeah
right so I hate drama shows about it in
NBA do social media do you think that
you know social media is to think about
this like all your fantasy social media
guys think they're you know because it's
a lot more direct and you know you you
get to see from the audience themselves
and not just a poll or an idea
you you get to see through the hashtags
and you know we were trending every
night and yeah you see through the
hashtag even when when we got canceled
we were trending we started trending and
hash tagging and all these sorts of
things so for me you know this is
definitely my first experience having a
fandom that is one this involved and
this vocal and having the effects reach
to the pitch it reached is just for me
definitely unparalleled and apparently
it was for NBC as well because they
brought us back three days later I am I
think I think it's incredible just as a
fan myself like other things and
projects I think it's so cool that the
fans are so empowered now to to bring a
show back to life that's I feel like
that's unprecedented
so it's power to the people now have you
started working on the next season yet
no honey any idea ever any idea what you
guys are going to be doing which we have
some idea we definitely want to keep
things under wraps we have our creator
writer showrunners Sean Ryan and Erica
here today and and they've shared with
us some of the ideas for next season
which I think are phenomenal but this
season we're also going to be shooting a
paramount in Los Angeles so I think it
opens up a lot more stories than maybe
we'll see what we can explore maybe some
old Hollywood
if I keep adding it hard enough yeah is
there a story about traveling back in
time to the 2016 election is that in
there at some point yeah we wrote that
yesterday we're going to hit that
exactly the writers were all going Oh
we'd like to go back to right now yeah
we do have a room yeah I appreciate your
concern but we're one of the rules of
the show is that you can't go back to
when you were previously alive yeah you
can't go back in your own where you
already exist all right that magnetic
shield that oh I'm sorry
all this water spoilers now about your
religious studies mark yeah so Jesus was
actually a Jew and he was a carpenter
everyone guys are nailing this mailing
myth yeah so having worked on the show
is anybody here now like a bigger
history buff like you guys have more
interest in the history of the world he
did before I do I do I become a history
buff but I've been like it last for like
a week I'm like oh this is really good
but then I have to move on because we're
good because I think we're inundated
especially for us we're caught in these
timelines all day like we're caught in
like three different timelines like
daily while we're shooting so it's like
very hard to keep it all together but
we're constantly learning from these I
think what the writers do is they do a
good job of taking things that you sort
of know and getting even further
in-depth into there now we have a really
cool experience because the Smithsonian
invited us to be their lead show and
kind of the leading thing that they
showed at the Film Forum which they have
every year and they said in front of
many many people that it's the most
accurate show that they've seen on
television ever hey kudos um yeah yeah
now you mentioned old Hollywood but is
there any era specifically that you guys
would love to explore oh Jesus yeah yeah
the resurrection story